[Applause]
oh we got to talk about our man van
lathan bro won the oscar yo
son so this is tragic yo our man van
latham wins an oscar for
a short film the film wins the oscars oh
sorry the film with
oscar this is dove hayton yeah that's a
very late thing
why would you do that though i don't
even know the difference that was some
shade
that's a shame bro that's some shade
that's his name because you don't got
one yet like
yeah not yet yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
amazing accomplishment
so van latham won best picture van
lathan was protecting him in case yeah
he was the star of the movie that won
the audience
he produced it he won all the oscars
yeah he produced he produced because
that's what makes him the star
exactly he's the star he's the star star
producer 100 and um
called two distant strangers uh and then
this chick
pops up on on um tick tock right
this asian chick pops up on tick tock
like yo
i'm not saying anything but this story
and plot line is very similar to a
sketch that i put out
now two distant strangers essentially
groundhog day for a black dude he's
trying to avoid getting killed by the
cop
yeah and he's doing all these things
different in his life to avoid getting
killed by the day he keeps having an
overnight the day keeps happening over
and over again
and the cop keeps getting them right
um are you smiling i mean hot you can't
but you can't not give that the oscar
yeah the white people in that room are
like come on yo
come on yo last year it's a movie about
like one guy getting killed by a cop
that what if it's one guy this is their
groundhog
and over and over for their groundhogs
we gotta get the black
[ __ ] something next year it's gonna be
inception
it's black guy's inception where he goes
to an alternate universe and then he
gets killed by a cop
this happens to every universe black guy
lands on mars yeah he gets killed
cop shoots him immediately yeah like
[ __ ] dude all right so then
this asian chick puts out uh had put out
a sketch a while back
uh called like a day in the life of a
black guy and i guess no it's literally
called groundhog day for a black man oh
is a worse title it is way worse way
worse title groundhog day for a black
man
and it's a sketch where what over and
over again
he goes who gets killed by a cop gets
killed she puts it on like 20 17.
yeah a lot of views now this you've
heard of the company now this yes
now this comes and asks her if they can
post
the video on their platforms she
acquiesces they post on the platforms
now a interesting thing that happened
with van's two distance strangers
is it was also produced by
now this so the asian chick is like hey
yo this is crazy
she wasn't coming at the creators of the
movie but she was like now this is
involved is now this taking my product
and then getting it made et cetera so i
hit van up last night i'm like yo van
what's the deal with this
and he goes look bro we didn't take that
from anybody
we didn't even bring in now this until
after we had done it
so if there's any person here who's a
piece of [ __ ] or company
it's now this now this saw it pop off on
their social media
and it goes crazy and they're like oh
this idea is brilliant it got all these
views and then all of a sudden they hear
about this movie that's getting made
and they go oh we know that our fans
love this or this thing killed
let's attach ourselves to this idea that
we know is going to do really well
that's the most nefarious approach
i think there is another approach where
the social media team is completely
separate from the content
acquisition team and the content
acquisition team is hey this is a really
good thing it goes with our like woke
strategy we definitely think that this
is going to be oscar nominated it could
look really good for us
and it just so happened that they
reposted a piece of content which they
probably repost
thousands of different videos every year
maybe and because the brand is linear
and they all it's in
agreement with each other they're like
yeah we liked it then we like
they didn't even really that's that's
what i'm imagining i didn't even make
the connection to van because
whatever but they i remember in her
video she said something about hitting
up
now this and netflix and saying
something like hey would you guys like
to do something with this short film and
then
so you they contacted multiple
departments i assume and now this
yeah probably not the same social media
team handling the twitter and reposting
as opposed to
and what what often happens is when like
uh a comedian i think she was a comedian
i think she worked for like college
humor or something like that yeah but
like
when a creator doesn't have a big
backing and they ask a network for a
special or something like that they
oftentimes get told no
and then the same exact idea can get
made by someone who's a little bit
powerful a little bit bigger this is
experience in our
you know right professional career and
tons of other comics as well
uh or creatives as well for example
there's a movie someone wants to get
made
and then every production company's like
not interested and then leonardo cabrio
signs on to the movie and every
production company's like that's a great
idea for a movie yeah like this is just
how the industry works
right so what i think is i think this is
like
a really shitty coincidence like it
looks on the surface like yo they robbed
that [ __ ] and went with it
yeah but i'm believing it's a shitty
coincidence also that's my god van
and that's what he told me so i'm gonna
choose what my guy tells me but um
what is what is interesting is that van
also said like
he's like he's like in retrospect like i
wish we did our due diligence on the
idea like really looking because there
have been a couple other like sketches
there was either another full-length
movie that had a similar plot
and i was like bro like put that out
there yeah that helps you
yeah that just makes this idea parallel
thinking
if there's only two made in the world
then it looks tricky right
right but groundhog day things are
pitched all the time all the time
yeah right i mean if anything you all
ripped off groundhog day which is yeah
bill murray should be picked black
people are ruining everything
stealing my ideas white people's
groundhog days i'm going to kill myself
every day
white people are going i need to kill
something yeah
people are just killing bro it really
made me appreciate groundhog's day when
i saw how many people stole that idea
after
yeah and that came out in the mid 90s
and so they probably stole ground all
day yeah
yeah the ground is probably ripped off
from someone else yeah i'm just trying
to have a nice moment about groundhog's
day
he just said it why are you looking at
me well because
i was looking at you already and then
you were like yeah like i'm a [ __ ]
idiot for not knowing
but what what i guess finish what you're
saying i was just saying it's a great
idea you know what i mean that's
you see it's stolen all the time in
everything yeah the repeating days
whatever and this is the thing about the
internet we always talked about this
with like comedy jokes etc
it was it was a now that everybody is
posting their content there are millions
of videos posted every single day
millions of tweets ideas et cetera
posted
every single day right you're gonna see
how often
parallel thinking exists yes before when
there was like one special put out a
year on hbo
or eight specials put out a year on
comedy central or something
if you saw crossover between those jokes
you're like yo these people are stealing
i had to know
exactly now when you see a topical joke
put up like literally all you need to do
is go into the comments section of any
like reddit thread or even twitter or
whatever
youtube you'll see the same jokes
written i can't almost like kind of stop
doing it because like i would think of
these jokes that were like deep cut like
goofy like silly one-liners i would like
search it on twitter yeah and then
someone from like 2012 had like a
similar-ish idea
yeah and then i wouldn't do the joke
yeah and then you just do that with
every joke and they all have been done
in some version on twitter
exactly dude and that's what's being
exposed sorry but
that's what's being exposed by
everybody's ability to have a voice
is that we're gonna have similar ideas
and um
and it's [ __ ] it's really tricky and
you know kind of gets [ __ ] over a lot
of this like if i'm to make an argument
for snl is like
every time snl has a sketch that's like
similar to like what something a comic
put out or
joker kind put out or whatever the the
first thing we all jump to is oh my god
the writers on snl
stole that from that comic and that
could happen but the other thing we have
to look at is
snl is competing literally with every
other comic in the world
who can put out a sketch the next day
they don't wait till saturday not even a
sketch
a stand-up bit a tweet an instagram post
a quick little sketch that they put on
instagram like
they're literally competing with every
single idea another comic had in the
world
and if there is at all reflected in
their show
then that comic calls him out for
thievery yeah which it could be parallel
thinking
i get why they think that i get what i
think that and you also see a company
where people making tons of money and
usually it's a comic that's not making
anything so they're really upset
but there is parallel thinking and that
comment because it's parallel thinking
with other comics
etc i think that when when we always
look at like ideas
as a comic a lot of times it's not as
much like the premise it's oftentimes
like the vocabulary in words used
right any time i've seen somebody like
what i thought like
nip something from somebody or even
myself
i'm just like that's a pretty specific
word for that premise
it's pretty hard to steal a premise i
think like
but in order to steal like a joke it's
got to be like word for word and you
notice it
and like specifically the punch work or
like an act out or something
yeah so do the same movement with the
slap or something yes or like
uh hypothetical scenarios that are kind
of like unrealistic
yeah you know what i mean like we can
think of you know definitely when jamie
foxx took the prior thing
yeah like that hypothetical was just the
same yeah right so like you just see it
you're like oh that's a visceral these
are the same things
that are going on here um but it's
tricky and you're gonna see a lot more
of it and i wonder if it like
i wonder if it actually like is a better
creative world when we realize how often
parallel thinking exists
because then you'll go okay
it's okay that i do this joke even
though a random person on twitter
in 2012 had a similar idea it's okay
because so did maybe 100 other people
yeah and i'm going to build out this
joke and i thought of this joke myself i
i didn't you have to police yourself
like i didn't go on twitter and look for
it
this is my idea yeah it just so happened
another person thought this was
if you did nothing wrong i actually
think it's a nice thing to acknowledge
it
you know i mean like if you didn't steal
like for example uh lil nas x his music
video the montero one oh yeah he
definitely saw that the graphic
that's not even a it's the same video so
the graphics team that worked on his
video also worked on
fka twigs and they should have said
something because they just made the
same [ __ ] video
in a way yeah so like specifically in
like the they're getting abused by gay
guys at this point like
damn you
montero going into hell or whatever like
down the pole whatever on the pole yeah
it's like the same
like you ever see like the old disney
[ __ ] where they take like the old
animation and update it new
like it's the same thing with this fka
twigs girl in her music video yeah but
what he did i actually thought was a
good approach which was like
yo the graphics team that worked on my
video also worked on this one i didn't
realize it so shout out to her
check out all her stuff she's awesome
yeah it was cool i'm sorry that there's
that i stepped on toes or whatever yeah
it's like you already that's the best
way to handle it you put out the thing
already
throw them under the bus yeah yeah throw
them under the bus yeah then you
recognize what zero accountability for
completely stealing that person's work
and blame it on the production so that's
where it gets tricky is people who
do know they're stealing they're still
gonna steal i don't know
i don't know if he's still i it was just
hypothetically there if there's a person
who's like yo i'm just going to steal
and then if i get caught i'll just give
it up to that person and be like
but in the meantime i'm just going to
keep stealing and creating yeah so it's
tricky and maybe if you're that
production company you really want to do
that video
and you're pitching your best [ __ ] yeah
what is your best [ __ ] the [ __ ] that
already worked
with fk twix 100 oh i don't i don't of
course i can
believe they'd be like let's just do the
same [ __ ] like we're trying to think of
something new and revolutionary before
we already did that trying to save time
on
new graphics yeah maybe a hundred
percent yeah
like it's one scene and one little thing
like who's gonna care yeah
yeah it's yeah exactly it wasn't the
whole concept of the video but it was
just one thing but it was cool to see
him
go out and talk about it yeah and i
think you're going to see a lot more
than if it's done i think you can
acknowledge it if it's something that's
ongoing you can do it differently like
the way kevin hart did with uh
yeah inside jokes and he's like yeah
yeah this thing already exists my bad
for stepping on it yeah i realized
should have searched it and i'm going to
change the name
yeah yeah and i think it's like i don't
know if you're not intentionally
stealing i think it's
a good approach to like acknowledge it
that's what i said with kevin i was like
i don't think that this is on you i
think that
your team could have looked and i also
think this is similar to the now this
i was like siriusxm like you know
because it's come to you
like uh right you know like so like this
is where people
are so excited like i'm sure siriusxm
was so excited to do a show with kevin
hart they were just like yeah whatever
you want to do we'll do it
and um but it was cool if kevin to do
that i thought it was great right so i
think
if you're that oscar team i would just
be like yo this
pre-existing short film came out as a
similar concept and they do a great job
of illustrating
black strife in america yeah check this
out and the point was not the oscar of
the credit the point was the message so
check
this out check out these other guys that
have a similar idea check out these
other guys because it's for the greater
good
for illustrating the more this idea is
out there the more people it touches the
better so check out all of it
yeah the worst approach is being
defensive saying like like if they came
out with a public statement being like
this woman's clout chasing blah blah
like that's the worst yeah it was mad
funny though like because the reaction
to the girl was like
yeah mine dude stop asian haters
why are you stealing blackstone
literally people
listen asian [ __ ] why are you talking
about the black struggle why are you
profiting off of the black struggle
oh yeah i mean it won't go away because
normally with these like live-action
shorts that it won for like that can
become the full
full-length feature so it's not it's not
done but
let's see that happens all the time
that's why companies in hollywood are
like we do not
accept unsolicited material don't send
it
[Music]
that intern that opened up something
yeah so what happens
with this i i mean they keep the oscar
and i think it just goes away
i think van will acknowledge it in some
way in his pod but like can she sue
can she get anything i mean you how are
you going to prove for a fact she's like
a writer
copyright that's the thing the little
advice for any writers out there
register
your projects with the wga it's free
it's quick at least you're like you have
a record
boom yeah but then you'd have to prove
that somebody like saw that
and then chose it you have to do it
really well you can at least say
i did it first whether they stole it or
not i didn't steal it that's for
sure yeah